[Applaudissements]
on a plein plein plein plein plein de
choses à vous dire j'ai des coups de
coeur et des coups de gueule on aura
bien sûr et jal sont ce qui se passe là
on a plein de choses à voir parce que il
s'est passé plein de choses ce week-end
les chéris bien entendu on reviendra
avec capucine aussi j'avais lancé un
pari à capucine avec capucine si elle
arrivait à donner au moins une bonne
réponse pendant le jeu je devais venir
en slip aujourd'hui alors direz-vous
j'avais complètement oublié et que je
n'ai pas de slip ici nous avons canso
alors je bats talons or joly je n'ai pas
du tout moi et à moi j'aurais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors si vous avez vous assez bien sûr
il faut faire les missions qu'elles sont
et vous remonter un petit peu ça va
faire du bien pour le trimestre
[Applaudissements]